so let's see if we can find the
derivative with respect to X F e to the
x times cosine of X and like always
pause this video and give it a go on
your own before we work through it so
when you look at this you might say well
I know how to find the derivative with
respect to e to the X that's in fact
just e to the X and let me write this
down we know we know a few things we
know the derivative with respect to X of
e to the X e to the X is e to the X we
know we know how to find the derivative
of cosine of X the derivative with
respect to X of cosine of X is equal to
negative sine of X but how do we find
the derivative of their product well as
you can imagine this might involve the
product rule and let me just write down
the product rule generally first so if
we take the derivative with respect to X
of the first expression in terms of X so
this is we could call this U of x times
another expression that involves X so U
times V of X this is going to be equal
to and I'm color coding it so we can
really keep track of things this is
going to be equal to the derivative of
the first expression so I could write
that as u prime of x times just the
second expression not the derivative of
just the second expression so times V of
X and then we have plus plus the first
expression not its derivative just the
first expression U of x times the
derivative of the second expression
times the derivative of the second
expression so what you remember it is
you have to these two things here is
you're going to end up with two
different terms and each of them you're
going to take the derivative of one of
them but not the other one and then the
other one you'll take the derivative of
the other one but not the first one so u
derivative of U times V is a u prime
times V Plus u times V Prime now when
you just look at it like that it seems a
little bit abstract and that might even
be a little confusing but that's why we
have a tangible example here and I
color-coded it intentionally so we can
say that U of X is equal to e to the X
and
V of X is equal to cosine of X so V of X
is equal to cosine of X and if u of X is
equal to e to the X we know that the
derivative of that with respect to X is
still e to the X that's one of the most
magical things in mathematics one of the
one of the things that makes ysou
special so u prime of X is still equal
to e to the X and V prime of X V prime
of X we know is negative sine of X
negative sine of X and so what's this
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to the derivative of the first
expression so the derivative of e to the
X which is just e to the x times the
second expression not taking its
derivative so times cosine of X plus
plus the first expression not taking its
derivative so e to the x times the
derivative of the second expression so
times the derivative of cosine of X
which is negative sine negative sine of
X and it might be a little bit confusing
because e to the X is its own derivative
but this right over here you can view
this is this was the derivative of e to
the X which happens to be e to the X
that's what's exciting about that that
expression or that function and then
this is just easy next without taking
straight out there of course the same
thing but anyway well now we can just
simplify it this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to we could
write this either as e to the x times
cosine of X times cosine of X minus e to
the X e to the X times sine of X times
the sine of X or if you want you could
factor out an e to the X this is the
same thing as e to the x times cosine of
X minus sine of X cosine of X minus sine
of X so hopefully this makes the the
product rule a little bit more tangible
and once you have this in your tool belt
there's a whole broader class of
functions and expressions that we can
start to differentiate